I went from flat broke $40,000 in debt
to net worth millionaire that boggles my
mind a little over 10 years ago I just
opted out I chose the red pill I was
sick of being screwed over and I
followed a different plan called the
ramsy baby steps I went through
Financial Peace University I got on an
everyll budget and now for the past
decade I've been bucking the system
doing money differently no credit score
no credit card no debt just living a
life of Peace and Freedom this isn't
wishful thinking or Pie in the Sky
optimism I didn't make a million dollars
in Dogecoin or from Dave coin I didn't
get a big inheritance from a long lost
Rich uncle or have a secret trust fund I
decided to carve a new path with a new
mindset and new habits and that's really
unsexy and boring